I'm always comforting you Rosie I know
people you have it yes I talk to Madonna
she's doing good
I see her yes she's comforting you know
she's freaked out like everyone else is
everyone's freaked out about it right I
mean she goes in the bathtub and tells
you her feelings and do you ever get on
zoom' with her and say listen
Madonna I'm no one to tell you you've
had a very successful life but you
sitting in a milk bath you know talking
about your philosophy about coronavirus
how it's only great equalizer it might
come off as bagua do you ever say it or
can you be that honest with her well I
can be that honest with her I said it to
her about other things like I'd go to
her house for New Year's Eve and she's
having a big party and she has no shirt
on you know she has like two leather
strips right that go down and there it's
to the wind and I walk over I hug her
and I say in her ear you were the most
famous woman in the world go put a
[ __ ] shirt on so you know I have the
ability to to sort of do that did she
put her shirt on no she did not she did
the rest of the party sits to the wind
do we have favor get back to this zoom
thing I'm fascinated so let's say
because I don't have any zoom going on
I'm not in any zoom room I'm not on any
cocktail party this isn't that you're
telling me look let me have this take me
through this meg Ryan is on the zoom
chat with me Julie yeah Helen Hunt
Medusa
sander Jason Alexander I like I know him
Matthew Perry was on there Sean Hayes
and his partner his husband they're on
there so it's like a bunch of like 30 or
so people and we go on every night and
some people don't show up and it's you
know it's varied every night when you
get in the room yeah yeah I would assume
it gets political very fast if there's
some [ __ ] on it doesn't know it's
friends it's a group of friends it's
don't you start talking about Trump
right away and then what if there's
somebody on there goes you know and I
think Trump's doing a great job I mean
they're who thinks that number one I
don't have many friends who think that
so that
happen it's not really politics it's
more like how was your day how you
holdin up are you doing alright you know
and then someone tells something that
happened with you know their life and
then I'll you know complain about my
kids about you know worrying about my
children my son and the Marines and
everything it's you know all the things
that make you you can kind of share it
there with everyone and is there a
celebrity on there who has a shitty
internet connection and you get annoyed
in other words every time they open
their Yap they cut in and out and I know
you threatened to throw them out of the
room never happens but you know Howard I
tried to do a zoom room the other day
for like fans like I put up a code on my
Twitter and said come on and we'll talk
for a minute well we got hacked with
porno hey man it was a woman who was not
really very judicious about what holes
were used and it was I was like what the
hell so now I'm afraid to do another one
you